hey I was gonna breasts - I'm so excited
and happy because I did a video this
game and I didn't think anyone would
like it because I didn't know so many
people were familiar with this game and
so many people shared the same love that
I have for this game it's just it's one
of the classics alright so we're gonna
continue playing we have our park was a
call again Jesus Christ
but park but park means soap what that
[ __ ] are you doing stop mowing the line
so I got so much amazing support from
your brother on this episode so I want
to also incorporate you bros ideas and
one of your bros ideas was anytime
someone does something bad I'll just
drown them I'll just draw
so we have our little handyman here
where is he asked my number two sorry to
let you go but how about you do your job
next time oh my god he's trying to
escape there you go
he's drowning how much are we paying him
ask men to has drowned
what'd you get ask man the most money
I'm we're making is loop my ass baby
which one is that
yeah that's that's the money maker after
that we have the asset puller that's
pretty good what baton they're [ __ ]
information Charles keeps making it
alright ask formation shots humor okay
we have to build a new attraction we
need to make some money got to make that
money I think it's time for a wooden
roller coaster do you brush told me the
reason why people don't go on my roller
coaster it's because it's too scary so
let's build one for [ __ ] all right
yeah oh so scary oh boy I sure hope this
isn't too scary for those [ __ ]
oh we just discovered log flume oh well
well [ __ ] this [ __ ] then uh I'm so good
at building these look at this this will
be amazing
this will be so good you'll lose your
[ __ ] head
I wanna be the very best I know whatever
was catch them is my real test George
your bird I did it we did it as a team
that was intense
Bravo this game is giving me anxiety
right now I don't I don't appreciate
this okay I have an idea I have an idea
and it's crazy enough that it might work
all right
oh god what's happening over there they
don't have an exit I can't see anything
okay we got a new ride whatever it is
we're gonna build it
observe [ __ ] vation tower my god what
am I gonna do with a goddamn observation
tower Jesus Christ
think about the children it's gonna be
the best goddamn observation tower this
town has ever known oh my god I forgot
how stressful it gets Oh God
sorry guys I'm gonna have to delete this
line sorry
Oh God look how lost they are I feel
like I need to kill someone
I guess 495 I've been standing in the
line for that ass for a
well you won't be standing in line
anymore you're a dead man now you died
he died he died it's okay people die
these things happens it's fine it's
really just for this is so complex do
you see like the amount of thought that
goes into these they might have sheer
brain capacity my god how did I play
this game as a 12 year old little [ __ ]
alright we're building tunnels now look
we're building underground that's when
you knew you're like really [ __ ] MLG
at this game cuz when you build
underground and [ __ ] like that's when
you know you would get a lot of [ __ ] in
school because you know how to drill
into granite [ __ ] you know I'm saying
look at that [ __ ] we got a problem we
solved it with our [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
formation Cox is the most second most
profitable Jesus Christ we really need
to up our prices you know what we need
we need a wooden [ __ ] roller
coaster and I can't be bothered to build
it myself so we're just gonna do a
prebuilt [ __ ] I don't know how
many hours of my life that I've spent
just trying to figure out like how to
construct a building in a certain spot
cuz the goddamn trees always ruins it
you ruined my life trees so expensive to
delete trees oh my god BAM we're gonna
be rich
we're gonna be [ __ ] rich again bros
all right whatever gap but we got people
going people going pimp going over doing
good we're doing good it's good it's
going good it's doing good right student
making money make it matter I'm making
about it make it a money I'm making it
my way downtown walking fast faces pass
yes [ __ ] becoming in our we get we're
gonna build a [ __ ] park here it's
going to be [ __ ] amazing they're just
gonna come in here and be like holy [ __ ]
this park is so beautiful and it won't
be the most disappointing part in the
country
you know when you go to a bathroom and
you're like oh [ __ ] it costs money this
game makes you understand this game feel
the hunger it's starting to rain it's
starting to rain information tossed
everywhere up the prices an umbrella up
the prices on umbrellas everyone haunted
house that fits the rain doesn't it
there we go let's build it right [ __ ]
there
now amazed I love maces in this game
let's build our own mace that'd be cool
right I'll get us [ __ ] not everyone
is as fast as building as me it just
comes with talent and a lot of brain
capacity yep one day you will be as good
as I am at building maces but today is
not that day [ __ ] all right that
guy's just about to throw up let's
murder him there you go enjoy hell
[ __ ] Oh new attraction [ __ ] yes
whoo yes I love this one this one is my
favorite this game is the most hardcore
game of the century people can't keep up
that throne fault
look at his [ __ ] rollercoaster park
yes look at it we're deleting a slider I
know it hurts my soul as much as it does
for you but we need we need that money
let's build this here that will make us
that money yeah boy that's right give me
that money we got some [ __ ] cars
going and [ __ ] but cars
yep that's humor look how the amazing
ass is going look how great that is
I bet they love it let's see what they
thinking oh we did it we did it I
thought it was three years but it was
just one year the goal was to have 250
guests we had a [ __ ] thousand and at
least a rating of 600 our rating was
probably way better we did it
we completed the first level you know
what that means
that means we unlocked a new one we're
gonna have to end that episode there if
you bros enjoyed keep living your
support I really really truly appreciate
it thank you both so much and as always
thank you for watching I'll see you in
the next one
stay awesome your Park receive their
award for being the most disappointing
[ __ ] you